the best game I played at e3 is
battlefield 4 simply because a sheer
scale of the game is so enormous Mario
Kart 8 of course I'm big into Nintendo
that's kind of my console the new Saints
Row is fantastic it's you have like a
dubstep gun where it just goes you want
won't want makes people jump up and down
and stuff like that of cars and you have
like matrix force powers and stuff
Saints Row has gotten continuously more
ridiculous as a use have gone on first
of all I love love a good scary game so
I've always been a fan of the horror
genre had a chance to play outlast if
you played amnesia amnesia is nothing
compared to a less I've played amnesia a
little bit on my channel but outlast is
like it blows it away I screamed like so
loud and the booth everyone turned and
looked at me but it was really really
fun I mean he screamed like a little
girl a lot
I screamed like a girl and literally the
entire booth turned and looked at me it
was really embarrassing actually
surprisingly a lot of the things in the
IndieCade blew me away just because
they're simple that was something that
was surprisingly surprisingly surprising
for the 3ds they had Yoshi's
Island and I really really want to play
that your she's story but the line was
way too long the lines were just
ridiculous I thought I was waiting in
line to play the game and it's like son
of a [ __ ] all I get to do is watch
these other people play it and have fun
when I want hands on things that I
really liked the most was Batman Arkham
origins it was really fantastic hands-on
I'm a huge Batman fan so I was giddy
when I got to play arkham origins got a
little hands-on time oh I'm still a
little bummed that they're going back in
the timeline and not progressing forward
but at the same time it's Batman and we
have Joker back so it's fantastic the
new Kinect is like so much better so
much more high-resolution way better
sensors everything and probably just
going to get an Xbox one just to get our
hands on the new Kinect sensor first and
videos as a gamer it's really difficult
to pick a winner in the console wars
right now because we're just getting
started
Nintendo is totally out Nintendo hasn't
released a game in a really long time
and so they came out and said hey hear
all the games you wanted all right
Nintendo that's fantastic I'm excited to
see these games but they aren't out yet
Nintendo's coming out on top for me I
think I have to go with Nintendo even
though they had no real titles on launch
date they're making Mario Kart they're
making a new Smash Brothers which I love
PS yes they're making some good games
but as far as who won III I didn't feel
like they brought enough to show us to
really make me be like ps1 and Microsoft
can't win because of their ridiculous
DRM issues where you have to connect
once every 24 hours and they're just
like fu to people who don't have
internet you guys can't win I'm sorry so
you got Xbox versus PlayStation now
everyone is given Xbox a lot of problems
about similar technology and Sony won
the conference because they kinda just
gave jabs like hey guys we support use
games and yeah if you want to share
stuff that's fine oh and you don't have
to connect every 24 hours how to share a
ps4 game and that's just a guy handing
this his ps4 game someone else and he's
like thanks
no PlayStation had a fantastic
presentation and they really kind of
like stuck it to Microsoft and some of
the DRM and online issues
I fully believe the Xbox one is the
winner in technology for next generation
they just did a really poor job of
presenting their tag but when it comes
to like looking at the two tech demos
between the two Xbox one wins the Xbox
up is tech wise so far superior than
what Playstations green on the table
right now that's why it's costing the
extra hundred dollars so for me those
other problems don't affect my life
whatsoever
and I think that they're coming out
stronger with a better lineup of games
so for me personally I think Xbox is
gonna win it because I their issues they
don't affect or bother me